The problem here is that the scale used
here is inconsistent. Four stick people are originally used
to represent 43,000 nurses. However, 28 stick people
are then used to represent an increase of just
3,000 nurses. And then, just after that, about
eight stick people are used to represent an increase
of only about 1,000 nurses. As you can see,
this growth doesn't follow a linear or logarithmic scale.
It's just kind of random, and it's very confusing to the reader.
You'd look at this and think that the number of nurses exploded, but
it really only increased by 3,000. We can only assume that some kind
of mistake was made here, that
this doesn't efficiently communicate what's actually happening.